Welcome to the GDPR seminar
everyone. Before we introduce
our invited speaker, let's go
over some rules and logistics.
First of all, please mute
yourself during the talk. But if
you have questions, you can
unmute, and ask questions or use
chat room to post your questions
so that we can address them in
training session at the end.
Second, today's DDPS seminar is
open to external audiences.
Therefore, no classified
discussion is allowed. So please
watch out. Finally, the talk
today will be recorded and
uploaded in our YouTube channel.
That's about it. Now let me
briefly introduce our speaker
today. It is an honor to host
Dr. Jean long Lu who is an
assistant professor in the
Department of Mechanical
Engineering at the University of
Wisconsin at Madison. The
current research of his group
mainly focuses on developing
data driven methods to learn
closer models for complex
dynamical systems, for example,
multi scale multi physics and
chaotic systems from direct and
indirect data. Before joining
utopia, mass Madison, he was a
research scientist at Caltech
working on a data driven climate
modeling project. He got his PhD
PhD degree in aerospace
engineering at Virginia Tech in
2018. And his dissertation is
about using Bayesian inference
and physics important machine
learning in turbulence modeling
today Jinlong will present an
exciting topic, which is data
driven closure modeling using
derivative free common methods.
I'm sure we will hear an
exciting talk today. But before
I pass the baton to Jinlong, let
me ask a couple of questions.
With you know, just to get to
know you better, and to make
this seminar somewhat informal,
obviously, you're passionate
about data driven closure
modeling in general, is there
any moments in your life when
you realize that? Wow, this is
it? This is the field I would
like to commit my career, if you
can share that moment. Yeah,
the interest along this
direction during my PhD study.
So first, I joined a group, many
focus on the condition of
dynamics research. The just
because one of the focus of the
research is turbulence modeling,
and existing turbulence models.
I'll say many of them, not good
enough for real applications and
motivators to see okay, given
the fact that amount is
increasing rapidly in past few
decades, can we leverage some
data driven modeling techniques,
try to help the predictive
capability of the existing
models. And that actually leads
me to further explore this
direction.
Yeah. Awesome. Awesome. Last
question. Second question. I
understand that you are starting
your career as an assistant
professor. Although it was
short, would you share your
experience being a professor at
a university good or bad? It's
very good. Very good. Okay.
Yeah. All right. And the
research here is fantastic.
Fantastic. And a lot of
collaborations with within the
faculties and other other
department as well, I guess.
Yeah. Awesome. Awesome. All
right. Sounds good. The stage is
yours in law.
Thank you very much for the
introduction and the questions.
So thanks again for the
invitation. Today, I'm going to
share some recent works about
data driven closure modeling
using 33 kind of methods. So the
general motivation, this
direction of work, can you see
my no somehow it's gone. Can you
see the screen? Yes. Okay. So,
the general motivation for this
direction of work is changing
proof the modeling of complex
dynamical systems, for example,
the Earth system, some energy
harvesting, or rovers on Mars,
or some kind of very complex
physical systems involved in
engineering applications, and
common pain. The feature of all
these systems is that they often
involve multi scale or multi
physics process. Since for which
we cannot afford to numerically
simulate every details. For
example, if we take a look at
the Earth system, we will have
the cloud microphysics at
millimeters up to the planetary
waves can be 10,000 kilometers.
So as this large wrench scales,
it would be almost impossible to
simulate everything else within
the system. And that's why
closure models are usually
needed for some unresolved
degrees of freedom and the talk
of today then their focus would
be to answering your question
How to Improve closure modeling
for complex dynamical systems by
using some data driven methods
okay. And before diving into the
details, I like to briefly
introduce what I mean by culture
problem. So, let's assume that
if we have the original system,
follow this kind of general form
of the and in practice the
origin of system state use more
you hear almost kind of involve
very high dimensional space and
simulating every details of that
would be very, very extensive.
And in practice, what people
like to do instead of directly
solving this equation for
engineering problems, people
will try to introduce some
reduce order state capital U.
The methods to introduce this
kind of reduce order state
include, for example, car
screening, is a are more recent
in the auto encoder. Once we
decide what kind of reduce order
states we want to work with, it
will not be difficult to derive
a corresponding common equation
for this capital U. But the
problem is that for the origin
of Dynamics F, it's usually
named nonlinear, which means
that the derived exact form for
this reducer state usually not
only involve itself, but also
involve some misinformation
carried by the unresolved
original system state. So the
closure modeling means that we
want to propose approximation f
tilde that only depends on the
information that we simulate,
which means the capital U here,
and hope that the F tilde can
well approximate the bar the
exact dynamics for this reduce
RF state. But in practice, we
know that it is not usually the
case that f tilde can
approximate f bar very well. And
that's why in recent years,
people start to think about a
question, can we quantify the
difference between these two f
bar and f tilde was an
additional term M and M
basically characterize the arrow
made by f tilde? And the next
question is that can we use some
data to help us determine what
will be a good m should look
like. So to make a choice, the B
or people call it direct data,
which means that was the hair
data information about you and
the true evaluation of M on the
corresponding view, if we have
this kind of data pairs, we can
directly use standard regression
methods to turn this unknown
error term. If we want to use
direct data to achieve that,
that means that we need to
estimate the evaluation of M on
some system state capital U.
that involve either we evaluated
this kind of difference, we use
the temporal derivative minus
the approximation of tilde or we
can directly use the difference
between f bar and f tilde to
help us get the data about the M
evaluate on some of you. But
both approaches they share some
issues in practice. The first
approach if we want to get a
good approximation about the
temporary delta here is usually
not practical because your data
may be noisy or even sparse in
time, which means that
estimating this term accurately
is sometimes difficult in
practice, on the other hand,
getting the f bar in order to
assess the difference between
the two will involve simulating
the original system and get the
information at small you
unresolved.
Interrupt, there's a question
from Chevy, I think it's better
to answer that right now. So,
ask about what is the Decker
superscript before
Oh Decker indicate that the
system state corresponding to
the true system. So, you can
think that whenever we put the
debtor here remain that this u
is gathered instead of
simulating this approximate
system is gathered either by
kind of sensor from the true
system or if we have some high
fidelity simulation and we post
processing to get the
corresponding capital U for the
true system. Okay. And, as I
mentioned that, those kinds of
approaches, if we want to use
direct data, which means u and
M, evaluate on you, as training
data pairs, we will encounter
problems in practice. And that
is the main reason that
motivates us to think
alternative approach instead of
using regression standard
techniques to kind of cin this
error term, can we just use some
indirect data, so, which means
that we just have some
observation about the true
reduce all other systems that
can tell you and instead of
assuming that we can directly
get the corresponding valuation
of M on U dagger, we just rely
upon this kind of indirect data,
can we try to get good form of m
and calibrated. So, this talk
will focus on the use of this
type of data or we call it
indirect data. And I will many
demonstrate the learning this
unknown error term by using what
we call it coming version. So,
the next slide, I will briefly
summarize some key features
about the ensemble coming
version Aki, which is the
optimization method we use to
help us category to that unknown
error term. So, the ingress
problem we try to solve in
journal form can be viewed as
the top equation here, we have
some data y and we also have
some forward map G that met the
unknown parameters theta to the
data space an error here just
characterize the noise
associated with the data
generation process and epi
formula is intuitive formula and
j here indicates the index of
ensemble and M represents the
index of eti step. So, for the
AMS you can I step if we look at
here, we will have the current
estimation about unknown
parameters theta and then we
will be able to plug in the
current estimation into the
Florida Map such that we will
get the corresponding results in
data space. But we know that
current estimation may not be
good enough, which means that
comparing to the true data,
there will be some mismatch
between these two. And then we
first use normalization factor
try to normalize this mismatch a
little bit here, gamma just
indicate the occurrence of the
noise and the capital G G
letters here indicate the
covariance within the data space
produced by the Ford Model T.
And we first normalize this data
mismatch in data space. And then
we have another covariance
matrix between the parameter
space and the data space. And we
use this to project the
normalized mismatch back to the
parameter space and use that to
adjust our current estimation
about theta. And then they will
give us the result for the theta
estimation for the next Aki step
and we will do that iteratively
until we achieve some
statistical convergence And at
the bottom, I just briefly list
a few advantages of using acai.
The first point is that as you
may have noticed that for this
updating formula, all we need to
access is the Ford map G
evaluation, we don't require any
gradient information about the
format G, which means that the
method that we present here is a
derivative free optimization
method. And also in practice,
people find that the ensemble
coming version just because his
ensemble base mattered, it tends
to be robust to noisy
evaluations of the forum apogee.
And also the core task here
actually is equivalent to a
convex optimization problem,
which means that we can easily
incorporate some additional
constraints into this
optimization process. And for
the third part, I will revisit
that in more details for the
second part of this talk. But
before that, let's get to the
first part of this talk the data
driven turbulence conversion
modeling. So, as we already know
that turbulence actually is
ubiquitous in many types, flows,
and in practice, Reynolds
average navier stokes neurons
models are still widely used in
turbulence simulations, even
though they have limited
predictive capability for
complex flows. So if we take a
look at the rest equation, we
will say that the only term
needs to be modeled as sitting
at the right hand side here is
what we call Reno stress, how,
and the difference between the
touring stress and rents model
Reno stress is usually unknown
to us. If we can characterize
this difference in a relatively
accurate way, and then we can
use this difference to help us
further improve the predictive
capacity of the rents
simulations, okay. And the
general goal, this kind of part
is tried to propose pipeline
helpers to characterize the
difference between those two and
use that to improve the rent
simulation. And the example that
I'm going to use is, well, we
called flow over periodic hills.
And the geometry of that flow is
presented at bottom. So we have
solid wall on top and bottom.
And the general flow direction
is from left to right. And we
have periodic boundary condition
for both inlet and outlet. And
we assume that we have some
sparse measurement of the renal
stress.
Sorry, the res modeled velocity
you. And the goal here is try to
estimate the full field.
Reynolds stress discrepancy,
whether it's the delta tau here,
which means that as long as we
have some data, as far as the
space about the capital, you
hear, can we try to estimate the
delta tau as the full field. And
if we can do that, we can use
that to help us improve the
rents model, we're not stressed,
and then we can prove the
simulation results after events.
Okay. So that will be the
general goal. And before diving
into the details of the results,
I'd like to briefly go through
the summary of algorithm. So at
beginning we assume that we can
sample some realizations about
the delta tau, the Reno stress
discrepancy from some prior
distributions, and then we'll
have some ensemble of the Delta
Tau. With that, we can plug in
this ensemble initial points
about the bounce house into the
border model of the rent solver.
And then we can try to simulate
to get the corresponding
velocity field u, capital U
here. And then we can compare
the simulated velocity with the
elevation data which is just the
sparse velocity at certain
location. And we use the
difference between these two to
help us update the estimation
about the ensemble of delta tau.
And we do that intuitively until
we achieve some statistical
convergence about delta tau. So
behind this general pipeline,
actually, what we're doing here
is the Bayesian inference. So
assuming that we have some prior
distribution about how, and this
sparse observation provide us
some likelihood model about the
probability of observing those
velocity on those points
conditioned on the given delta
tau. And then with these two, we
want to evaluate the posterior
distribution, which means that
the probability distribution of
delta tau, given the
information, the velocity
observation on those sparse
points, okay. And here,
actually, there is a question I
haven't answered yet, is that at
first, we assume that we have
some prior distribution that we
can sample the sample of delta
tau, that will be the starting
point of this algorithm. And the
natural question would be how
can we construct this prior
distribution for the delta tau.
So for the next slide, I will
briefly introduce how we
construct the price version of
the data towel. So in our work,
the price model is Gaussian
process, whereas the covariance
matrix in this detail form
whereas the square exponential
kernel and the prior knowledge
is used to specify the field of
barons, which is just the sigma
here, the sigma is fueled with
inputs, spatial coordinates. And
for this specific flow, we know
that the rains models tend to
perform now good in this fresh
air region and also this
recirculation region. And that's
why we empirically assign larger
values for the field of bearings
for the sigma. And after that,
we can use slowly called Kohala
expansion, try to get the
corresponding basis functions
that we can use to reconstruct
the Gaussian random feud down at
home. So at the bottom, I
present several leading
components, the candidate basis
functions, and by linearly
combine this different modes.
And then we can have different
realizations, this Gaussian
random field for the data at
home. And that is equivalent to
say that the remaining task is
try to estimate how would be the
optimal way to linear combine
all the spaces functions such
that we can have good that had
helped. And more rigorously,
that means that we parameterize,
the standard how, by using the
basis functions we obtain from
the Kornilov expansion, and we
near combine them together using
some unknown coefficients that
high and the remaining task is
given the sparse anticipation
data about the velocity, we want
to estimate the posterior
distribution of unknown
parameters set high, given the
information, the sparse
observation of velocity. Okay,
so with the brief introduction
about the algorithm, I'd like to
show some results about this
specific case. So on top we have
the prior distribution of the
simulated velocity field, some
vertical profiles, and on the
bottom, we present the posterior
velocity distribution on the
same vertical profiles. Here,
the green lines indicate the
ensemble of the simulation. So
each line correspond to a
different realization of the
health and blue lines here
correspond to the sample mean,
and realize here correspond to
the baseline rents results,
which means that we just use a
existing res model without
correcting it. And blank lines
here correspond to the direct
numerical simulation data, which
is a high fidelity simulation,
we view as the tubes and black
crosses indicate the location
that we put the sensors such
that we can gather the
corresponding data acity data on
this points. And as we can see
that if we sample delta tau from
the prior distribution and
plugging into the forest Solver,
we will get the scattering
velocity profile for the
simulated velocity on every
point. And we also have the
scattering, whereas the baseline
array is approximately sitting
in the middle. And if we
incorporate data and try to
estimate the optimal choices for
those unknown parameters theta
that help us characterize the
data, how field and then the
updated velocity field using the
posterior distribution of the
delta of how it's presented at
bottom, as we can see that in
many regions, especially the
recirculation region, we
achieved much better agreement
with the choose the high
fidelity simulation DS here,
compared to the red lines, the
baseline red simulation. So, as
I mentioned that that example,
is just one of the example that
we try to characterize air model
based on some indirect
measurement data. In that
context, the air model itself is
the full acute renal stress. And
the indirect data is just the
sparse activation at the
velocity field. As some of you
have noticed that, in that
example, we use the assumption
that the renal stress that how
is function instead of the
result, system state, the
velocity you we assume that is a
function of spatial coordinates.
And more recently, there is
extension that work that extend
the assumption of Reno's just
answer to the velocity itself.
And if you are interested in
that extension, I highly
recommend to the reference list
on the bottom. Okay, I think I
see some questions. Should I
stop and try to answer them?
Oh, it's up to you. However, you
will, yeah,
maybe we can try to answer those
questions.
Okay. Do you want me to? Okay.
There is a question from
someone. In slide nine, I
believe that's what he meant by
G nine, we see a discrepancy
between DNS and posterior mean
value, implying that there's a
modal form error in parameterize
Vinos stressful model, do you
have any comment on how such
error
so the marries and would be a
kind of restriction that we put
here by combining some basis
functions. So this kind of
solution space for the data
towel may not exactly cover the
to Reno stress discrepancy,
which means that we still see
some mismatch between the
optimal results that we can get
and the to reference the DNS.
But as I pointed in many
regions, we definitely see
noticeable improvement compared
to the baseline rents. The in
order to get closer to the
truce, I think what we need to
do is to propose some more
informative kind of basis
functions here.
I see. There's one more question
from John. On slide nine. Why is
DNS a single line and not a
family of blinds like the
samples?
That's the course for each
ensemble here that means that we
use a different choice for that
how tried to correct the rents
model rain or stress for the
tour in Australia is actually a
corresponding to the DS
simulation, which means that for
the s, there will be just kind
of one simulation instead of
kind of many, many or some
books. Yeah.
There was one more question from
Chevy, do you want to answer
that as well? Oh, yeah. Okay. He
asked, How often do you assume
measurement data are available?
Is it at each time step of the
baselines over?
That's a very good question to
clarify that actually, we are
looking at the steady case,
which means that the measurement
data is just taken in states.
And we are not considering the
unsteady case. And probably
that's the confusion why the DS
is kind of very serious looking
likes the choruses already time
averaged.
I see. relevant question from me
is that the sparsity of those
data in space probably affect
the performance. Right? Do you
have any idea how sparse and how
dense those data needs to be?
Yeah,
that's a great question. So in
this work, we just empirically
choose those data points, based
on our prior knowledge about in
which region rents platform not
well. Birds, if we want to kind
of do it's more rigorously,
actually, that relate to what
people call optimal design,
about the experiments.
Right. Okay. Thank you. No more
question for now.
Yeah, no worries. Okay, before
starting the next part, I think
I need to plug in the power.
Okay. Yeah. Then I mean,
in case that I disappear. Okay.
Sorry about that.
We'll take your time.
Okay, thank you. We are
glad that we have been q&a
session. All right, go ahead.
So then, let's move to the
second part of this talk,
imposing sparsity to assemble
coming version. Okay. So as I
mentioned, and a brief
introduction about Aki, that one
of the advantage of AKI is that
the core task is equivalent to a
convex optimization problem,
which means that if we want to
further incorporate certain
types of constraints, we can do
that in the framework of
constrained convex optimization
problem. Okay. And in order to
illustrate this point, let's
think that we introduce a new
variable w is just the
evaluation of the format. And
we'll use this new variable to
augment the existing vector an
on premises data, and then we
will also have the corresponding
Ford map that contain both data
and juicy data. And whereas,
this argumentation, we can
formulate a noisy observed
dynamical system in such a way
with the augmented system state
with data and W and here the h
matrix is just a projection
matrix H times B will give us
the W and the orthogonal part of
projection will give us the
theta. So, is all this kind of
manipulation about the new
system, then, actually applying
the AI updating formula every
step is shown as equivalent to
solving the bottom optimization
problem. So, the reason that is
equivalent to solving this
problem is that is equivalent to
applying the standard common
rotor to this augmented system.
And if we take a look at the
optimization problem, that we
are actually solving that
contains two parts. And for
those terms here, the key
feature is that they are
quadratic with respect to the V
vectors, which means that the
optimization problem that we try
to solve, although when we apply
the AKI updating formula, we're
not actually solving this
optimization problem, we use
that analytical form to give us
the next step estimation about
the unknown parameters, but this
process is equivalent to this
kind of quadratic or convex
optimization problem presented
at bottom and building upon
that, actually wait can refer to
its limit for the objective
function to make it more
compatible, whereas the standard
form quadratic programming. And
then imposing sparsity within
acai actually involves that
solving this standard quadratic
programming problem was this one
penalty or constraint, okay?
Remember that this projection of
v will give us theta, so what
we're looking at here is just
the ln norm of the unknown
factor, and we want that to be
small, so it's smaller or equal
to some constant gamma, okay.
And the good thing is that we
can relate the constrained
optimization specifically
imposing sparsity into acai with
this equivalent constraint
quadratic programming problem,
the the only problem here is
that the constraint here is not
the typical linear inequality,
which means that we cannot
directly call existing package
to solve this problem. In order
to address this issue, we borrow
the idea from famous paper than
now. So paper and we try to
introduce two variables,
auxiliary variables, the plus
and the minus such that we can
parameterize V and also absolute
value of v with these two
auxiliary variables. So, they
just correspond to the positive
and natural part of the V
itself. And whereas introducing
this auxiliary variables, we can
reformulate the constraint
quadratic programming problem
presented in the middle and we
have this kind of final form of
the quadratic programming
problem associated whereas the
auxiliary variables be passed,
and b minus. And the good thing
is that with this kind of
transformation, we will have the
standard linear inequality,
which means that for the bottom
problem, we can directly call
existing quadratic programming
package to solve that, and we
solve that as the additional
optimization once we have done
each Aki updating step. Okay.
So, should I stop here to answer
your question? You can go
ahead, I don't see any
questions. I can check. Okay.
Yeah. So then, after introducing
the details of the method, let's
take a look at a simple example.
So for the two system, we
started the model slashing ski
equation. So at the right hand
side of this equation, we can
see that we have three terms.
And for the model system, we
assume that we don't know about
the detail three terms, and the
right hand side, and we try to
use linear combinations of some
redundant bases, and try to
figure out what will be the
optimal choices of the
coefficients unknown
coefficients, alpha and beta
sitting in front of those basis
functions. And instead of doing
the calibration of alpha beta
using the standard system
identification approach, what we
assume here is that we only have
access to some time average data
of the user, instead of the time
series view. More specifically,
we're assuming that we have a
few moments of the new
autocorrelation of new and the
spatial correlation of the
system state you with that, we
want to see, can we estimate the
optimal choice for the alpha and
beta and in this problem is
designed in such a way that many
components of alpha and beta a
should be zero? Because many
basis functions, they are just
redundant. And we help
and you're right before, I
think, before the slide 18 There
was a question I missed it,
Adena, he asked how to check
whether this problem is getting
optimized at local minima or the
global minima. Are we using some
graphical methods to visualize
this? Very good question. So for
this one, we rely upon the
existing package for the cost
and convex optimization. So I
would say in most cases, the
optimal will be global optimal.
But there are certain cases, if
we run into some singularity
issue, that might complicate
things that that will manifest
in the estimated theta. Yeah,
which means that for their fate,
if we're plugging into the
format of G, we will see a clear
difference between the available
data we have. Okay. Let's
proceed with the result part. As
I mentioned, the goal is try to
match this time average data and
try to estimate the unknown
parameters alpha and beta. And
here, I just present the results
in dataspace, using the, what we
call the sparse epi. And for
center Aki actually, it can
achieve similar quality of
agreement in the data space. But
when we try to simulate the
system calibrated by both
methods under AI, and as far as
the acai, and we check the
profile evolve with time, as we
can see, clearly standard AI, so
quite different behavior than
the true system. And as far as
the acai agree is much better,
where's the trust system, and we
try to heart the unknown for all
the redundant coefficients,
alpha and beta. And we found
that for sparse EPI, the
algorithm managed to push the ln
norm for all redundant
coefficients to value very close
to zero. But that's not the case
for standard QA, which means
that if we don't introduce
sparsity in this case, just
because we only have limited
amount of limited indirect data,
we can run to the overfitting
issue in the data space. And if
we assimilate the category
system overfitting system, the
result may not agree as well
whereas the true system, but for
sparse and UK, I was we
incorporate the sparsity
constraint, we managed to
resolve this issue. Okay. And
so, for the rest of the talk, I
would like to briefly share some
efforts about going beyond
deterministic closures. So, as
we mentioned before that the
general goal is tried to
characterize difference between
f bar and tilde, and for most of
the existing works, we try to
characterize that with
deterministic error term. But in
some applications, especially
for the applications that we
have, kind of not a clear scale
separation, that usually happens
in many complex systems, that we
can not rely upon the simple
case that if we have clear scale
separation, and then or
unresolved scales, basically,
when they aggregate the effect
will not introduce any
stochasticity in the kind of
results system. But for the
system without a clear scale
separation. That assumption
might not hold true anymore.
That's why we try to introduce
additional term to characterize
the stochasticity due to
neglecting those unresolved
information explicitly. And
then, actually, that relates to
how to chain the M and sigma
more specifically, how to figure
out the unknown parameters
associated with the M and sigma
function here based on some data
and that relates to the standard
problem about estimating the
unknown parameters in stochastic
differential equation from some
data, and there have been
already different directions
that can achieve this goal. For
example, we can use creamer moil
Amridge, to try to read out the
m n sigma directly from time
series data or we can use
backward Ste or some stochastic
control approach to try to help
us optimize the alpha and gamma
unknown coefficients here or we
can assume some special
structure about the problem and
then we can use what we call
conditional Gaussian system try
to derive the analytical form
that can help us solve for the
unknown premiums alpha and gamma
Okay, before our target, we are
aiming at slightly different
scenario, that we assume that we
only have a limited amount of
indirect data, which means that
reading the drift, empty and
diffusion second term directly
from the time series data would
be impossible. And also, we try
to use the derivative free
optimization method because the
existence, this wiener process
will introduce some difficulty,
especially when we have this
kind of multiplicator noise term
sitting front in order
introducing clarity about
gradient if we want to use some
adjunct base metrics. That's why
we instead just try to stay with
this derivative free
optimization method that we have
introduced before the ensemble
conversion. And let me briefly
show two examples that we have
done along this direction. The
first one is what we call the
noisy Lorenz 63 system, or the
true system is just the standard
or insistent pass on noise. And
for the model system, we assume
that some part within the
standard system is unknown, and
also the diffusion coefficient
of the noisy system is unknown
to us. And we try to jointly
learn these two things based on
some time average data, the
system state X 1x two and x
three. And here I present the
result in data space. When we
use the stochastic term, or if
we just don't use the past term,
just try to use a deterministic
error term to characterize the
difference between the model
system and choose system.
As we can see here, that the
comparison against the true
data, both of them show good
performance, which means that we
can at least match the existing
data in data space. And the
natural question would be does
it mean the two models are
equally good? In order to answer
this question, we tried to
simulate both category two
systems for much longer time and
try to plot recall invariant
measure. If some of you are not
familiar with this terminology,
you can just think that as the
probability density function for
each system state variable, if
we simulate the system for a
very long time, as we can see
that, for the non term behavior
comparison, if we didn't enable
the stochastic term, and then
the imminent measure of the
characteristic system will be
noticeably different from the
true system. But if we joined in
learn the deterministic or non
term and also the stochastic
term together, we can say that
if we simulate for a much longer
time, the rent measure or long
term behavior of the model
system still agree is pretty
good, whereas the true system
but as you may see here is just
a toy example, that noise is
designed to be in this
structure, whereas some wiener
process and the next example, I
like to briefly show a different
setting. Now, we still focus on
our own system, but we are
studying the reduced order
setting that for the two are in
a system based on the results of
Professor Palmer about two
decades ago, that if we do some
pod transformation, we can
transform the system to a new
communist such that the third
dimension carries least energy.
So it approximately carries
about 5% of the system energy
which means that if we want to
build a reuse on our model,
straightforward thought of the
less just throw away this third
dimension of course, it's just
carry a tiny amount of the
system energy right let's just
get rid of it. And then we will
have a two dimensional system.
But in the original work, sir
Palmer, a found that that if we
simulated reduce our system, the
chaotic behavior basically
disappear, which means that the
reduced order system can not
characterize the true behavior
of the unknown system. The more
interestingly he showed that if
which just introduced some
noise, just why nice, and then
we can get the chaotic behavior
back at least qualitatively. So,
inspired this kind of
interesting phenomena, we try to
instead of just adding some
empirical white noise into the
reduced order model, we try to
add both deterministic and the
stochastic model into the
reduced order model. And we
tried to estimate M one m two
sigma and sigma two more
specifically, the unknown
parameters associated with the
models based on some time
average data of a one and a two.
And at bottom here, I just show
the key results of this example,
that if we try to calibrate the
honor M one m two sigma one and
sigma two terms based on some
time averages statistics of a
one a two and we are earning
them categorically model and
simulate the system for a much
longer time and compare the rent
measure against the shoe
invariant measure if anyone were
to instead of just getting a
qualitative chaotic behavior
back for the collaborative
system, if we use data to help
us category, more sophisticated
stochastic model, we can get
qualitative agreement and the
long term behavior for the
reduced order system. So, with
that, I would like to briefly
summarize what we have presented
here. The first is that many
complex dynamical systems
involved multi scale dynamics
without a clear scale
separation, for which
numerically resolving all the
scales is too expensive and
closure modeling is needed when
simulating the systems. And also
it demonstrated the learning of
closures based on indirect data.
It can be sparse activation
space, or it can be time average
statistics of your time series,
system state using ensemble
coming version. And I want to
emphasize that just because this
is a derivative free
optimization method, we don't
need to access the gradient
information of your Ford Model
G. And also sparsity constraint
can help avoid overfitting in
the learning of corrosion
models, when on a indirect data
is available, and the amount of
data is limited. And finally, we
demonstrate that derivative free
coming version methods also
enabling the learning of
stochastic coaches using
indirect data. So for those who
are interested in exploring more
about the common inversion
matters that I mentioned here.
So, at bottom, I just attach a
link about the package of
different conversion methods
that was developed and
maintained by the creamer group
at Caltech. So with that, I'm
happy to take questions. Thank
you.
Thank you so much long, there
was a wonderful, insightful
talk. Yeah, let's let's have a
q&a sessions. How I can start.
is,
you know, the, if you go back to
slide 14, you introduce like,
augmentation of new variable,
right? Yeah. I forgot the
notation for the new variables.
W, right. To make the AKI as an
convex optimization problem, is
it is it well known? Result? I'm
not familiar with the and simple
common inversion, that's
maybe, yeah, the first work that
systematically summarize this
kind of equivalency, I will say
can be found in this reference.
So it came out in 2019 90.
So it's not I guess, not long
ago, like three years ago, four
years ago. Yeah. Interesting.
And also, can you comment about
those, this computational cost
of PKI in general?
That's a good question. So in
general, the AKI just because
we're using the updating formula
Here is our sample base method,
which means that we need to run
a bunch of ensemble simulation,
specifically for the forward map
GQ, as long as we can kind of
have kind of parallel computing
resources, just because each
Ford evaluation here is like
kind of isolated, so which means
that they can be done in a
parallel way. And another kind
of expensive part here, some of
you may notice is the matrix
inversion here. And the good
thing is that for this work, we
only focus on the limited amount
of data, remember that the kind
of inversion we performed here
actually corresponding to the
dimension of the database. So
for the limited amount of data,
this kind of matrix inversion,
usually, it will not cause any
trouble, we can just use some
naive matrix inversion, some
kind of regular machines, but in
the situation that if we want to
perform kind of similar methods
in high dimensional data space,
and then we need to be careful
about the efficiency that this
matrix inversion key. But the
good thing is that the gamma
here is just diagonal matrix in
many cases, and the covariance
matrix here, as long as we
introduce some localization
technique, it can be a sparse
matrix, which means that the
efficiency of extending this
method to large scale problem
involve the efficiency of
solving the inversion of sparse
matrix. Awesome. Yep. Very nice.
Slide eight. What,
what is the motivation of
choosing crier as a decision
process? creation process as a
prior shocking Gaussian
processes?
Yeah, that's a great question.
So one motivation is that we
want to ensure some smoothness
about the sampled data. And if
we just assume Gaussian process,
and if we use square exponential
kernel, and then the sample it's
kind of done at how we came
through this, Muslims of that,
so that's kind of one critical
prior we want to incorporate.
Another reason that we rely on
caution is that it's less
expensive. So, if we want to
kind of sample from more
sophisticated kind of stochastic
process, it tends to be more
expensive. It's like a trade
off.
Yeah. Yeah, those are the
computational vision and the
Smoothness reason, but what if
the prior is not actually
Gaussian?
So, if the prior is not actually
caution, I will say instead of
directly sampling from that
prior, because sometimes caution
prior can be very expensive to
directly sample ways maybe we
can try to map caution to
negotiate. So along that
direction, so the non Gaussian
prior generation, because prior
is more about some kind of
modeling choices, if we really
have the kind of physical
justification to justify some
non Gaussian prior, I have seen
relevant work just focusing on
non caution prior generation by
using dense the generative
adversarial network basically,
you have the mapping from the
low dimensional Gaussian random
vector to high dimensional now
gotten LM actor and then the
mapped Now, question actor can
be used as the sample from your
non question try. Interesting.
Interesting.
Okay, thank you so much, Jen
long. Is there any questions
from audience? And they've been
diligent asking your question
during the talk, so
I'm happy to answer questions.
They are All right, good
questions
I guess I guess they don't have
questions. Well, but still, you
can ask questions in long by
emailing. And yeah, I'm sure
sumulong is will be very happy
to have any questions via email.
And also some collaboration
items. You will, you will be
happy to have a collaboration.
Yeah. Oh, I sense from ARB
enough. Does Aki works for high
dimensional problems,
yet. So I think that relate to
partially relate to a question
that we briefly discuss the
conditional limitation here. As
I mentioned, if we have high
dimensional parameter space,
that would not cause much issue,
because here is just kind of
high dimensional matrix vector
multiplication. But if the data
space is high dimensional, and
then the matrix inversion here
can hurt us, if we just use
naive will kind of standard
general matrix inversion
techniques. But as I mentioned,
as long as we introduced some
localization about this
covariance matrix, the course
anyway, we estimate this
covariance based on the
ensemble. And usually we don't
have enough kind of ensemble to
estimate on the covariance,
which means that we can just
focus on what we can estimate a
relatively accurate way to
localize that current structure
and just kind of thresholds,
other kind of long range
clearance. And in that way, this
matrix becomes a sparse matrix.
And in order to really
generalize this method to very
high dimensional data space, as
long as we can have efficient
sparse matrix, large sparse
matrix inversion algorithm, we
can apply them here, it will be
a separate kind of direction.
Adding up as the gain
localization means to reduce the
dimensionality.
Localization means that if we
estimate this covariance matrix,
that will be the dimension of
data space times dimension of
data space. And actually, some
of the off diagonal terms, we
don't have enough information to
just meet them accurately. And
then we can just threshold those
kinds of long range currents,
which means that we just pick
those kinds of shot wrench
covariance information and
introduce many zeros in other
parts of the matrix.
A way of specifying matrix. Any
other question? Well, if not,
let's thank our speaker Jean
long for a very insightful and
wonderful talk. Very nice. Thank
you. Yeah,
bigger approach or the rotation
and other questions. Thanks.
Thank you for the nice talk. All
right. Let's end here. Bye.